[Music]
Mariah Carey has a new duet partner
daughter Monroe Monroe is like this
incredible she's a great ear so she can
repeat what I sing to her and you know
that's a Telltale sign Mariah's 11 year
old joined her on stage during a show in
Toronto and fans were treated with the
surprise performance from The Duo
Mariah's first ever with Monroe
person
in my sky
[Music]
check out the pair and body the
Christmas season and sing Away in a
Manger to the sold out crowd the concert
is part of Mariah's two-hour special
Merry Christmas to all which airs
December 20th on CBS in Paramount Plus
[Music]
while this marks Mariah's first duet
with Monroe it's not the first time her
children have joined her during a
performance well they love being on
stage my twins rock and roll love being
on the stage Monroe and her twin brother
Moroccan often hit the stage alongside
mom most recently dancing along as she
performed during the Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade they're so brave they really
are I'm I'm very I'm very proud of him
she sang her classic Holiday Hits
[Music]
with you
baby I live for All I want for Christmas
is you I've I've grown to love it as the
writer I've grown to love it yeah the
songs even become a family car ride
favorite too
[Music]
and what
they love to sing and they love to be
they love to perform and they're they're
very dramatic and very they're hilarious
I mean they're hysterical and uh Miss
Monroe was definitely a singer and we
know Monroe's quite the performer Last
Summer She Sang while showing off some
moves to another one of her mom's hits
with Dad Nick Cannon
[Applause]
[Music]
I love making uh tick tocks with them
and stuff like that and I would say like
Monroe definitely gives you the Mariah
Vibe We can't agree enough check out
this mom and daughter moment from
October where they're totally 20. good
times we love it safe to say Monroe's
following in her mother's footsteps and
we can't wait for the next time they hit
the stage together again
[Music]
foreign